ah finally we're here after three weeks
of watching batman movie starting all
the way back with 1966 as adam west i
worked my way through keaton kilmer
clooney catwoman bale and now we arrive
with the batflick and of course the new
batman movie starring robert the pac-man
pattinson i've been open over the years
concerning my views on the modern marvel
cinematic universe however i've never
really spoken on what i thought about
warner brothers attempt to compete with
marvel in that same vertical this has
been a wonderful project to work on and
today we round it all off so without
further ado we're finally here i'm
toying that mark and kicking things off
this is my review of 2016's batman vs
superman dawn of justice
this was an interesting film to start
this video off with in 2016 i was
trolling around with my then girlfriend
at the time when the thought dawned on
us to go and watch the new batman vs
superman movie the title sounded
exciting albeit a bit dumb but we had a
few hours to kill in this scene like an
idea as good as any spoiler alert it
wasn't one instance i specifically
recalled from that screening was my ex
linear cross asking me who a particular
character was on screen and i replied
i have absolutely no idea what's going
on suffice it to say we did not have a
good experience and by the time we got
back into the car to head back home it
was a distant memory never to pop into
my head ever again i thought until now
when aj and i were mapping out which
movies i was going to be covering and
when he made certain to tell me not to
watch the theatrical cut of this film
which i had seen in the cinema but to
instead go with something called the
ultimate edition basically an alternate
cut of the film telling me that the
difference was going to be night and day
and to tell you the truth i didn't
believe him entirely
i mean i trust aj and i expected a
slightly better experience but still an
overall negative one spoiler alert i was
wrong what i once thought was an
incomprehensibly boring and rushed film
has suddenly transformed into a fun
superhero flake leagues pardon the pun
above that what i saw prior and
certainly better than what i was
expecting and i can't stress this enough
if you haven't seen this alternate cut
of the film that i'd honestly say give
it a look it completely changed my
perspective on the story now this isn't
to say that this film is without its
flaws glaring flaws but we'll get to
that
batman before tackling this three-hour
behemoth of a movie aj also provided me
with some required reading zack
schneider the director behind this film
has said an inspiration behind this
movie was a comic released in 1986
called the dark knight returns in which
a much older more aggressive batman
contends with tremendous loss much more
violence and even superman now with that
said it's far from a one-to-one
adaptation but there are some
interesting parallels the introduction
or credit sequence of the film's opening
is taken almost shot for shot from the
comic complete with pearl necklace beads
flying i am however glad that they
glossed over the origin this time around
as i've seen it way too many times in
the last three weeks between the comics
and films i've seen and to be honest i
think that's for the best we know who
batman is at this point and his
portrayal in this film is something i'm
very excited to touch on the way this
movie finally commits a horrifying
batman to the screen is to me one of its
strongest assets a dark hulking mask
that has villains convinced they saw a
genuine monster one of the earliest
scenes with batman rescuing prisoners is
constructed like a horror movie one by
one you hear the screams of men taken
out as the police officer scales the
stairs he turns and for a split second
you see the batman before he scuttles
across the ceiling away from view while
batman taking out villains in the
shipyard and batman begins goes a long
way in selling the horror of what batman
represents it's here that it's fully
realized and arguably the most comic
accurate direction it extends beyond the
horror too the whole notion that bruce
wayne is the mask is something i'm aware
is the most obvious take in the world
but i really enjoyed the way it was
utilized during the party scene where
bruce first meets clark under the
masquerade of a drunk billionaire he
james bonds his way into the restricted
area to do batman things and that's an
aspect that even the nolan trilogy often
didn't capture of course the portrayal
here isn't perfect in fact i'm aware
it's incredibly divisive years back when
i first watched this film something i
took issue with or at least felt stood
in my way in connecting with the
batflick was the killing he otherwise
commits unto criminals he shoots them
blows them up and even brands them and
while it makes for a cool visual the
fact that the brand is effectively a
death sentence once a marked criminal is
sent to jail kinda irritated me as i
watched it now however with the greater
awareness of batman and all the
incarnations he's had over the years i
don't find myself nearly as bothered
batman used to kill pretty ruthlessly in
his early incarnations and even after he
developed his moral code that's become a
foundation of the character there have
still been many instances where he's
killed one of the wonderful things about
comics is that different writers can
offer different takes on a singular
character and i think that's the best
way to take it here admittedly however
watching all of these films back to back
certainly makes this quite a jarring
take though it's as though christian
bale popped up in a fourth movie taking
people out ruthlessly without the
development to showcase what brought him
to this point and i think that's a large
part of why this bothers many people
including myself to a minor degree
you're dropped right in on a post-robin
death batman one that's lost his code
and moral compass without quite
understanding how he ended up this way
in the first place he's an unyielding
unkind and violent person in this film
but not without purpose and i think the
way it's portrayed overall does just
about work his actions are not glorified
or accepted as permissible the entire
point of this version of batman is to
highlight how bruce has fallen as a
human being there's a brilliant quote
from jeremy irons alfred that speaks to
this very flaw in this film he says and
i quote that's how it starts sir the
fear the rage the feeling of
powerlessness that turns good men cruel
he's judging bruce in this instance and
this very aspect of who bruce is this
cruelty this savagery this lack of moral
ethic is exactly what this story serves
to draw attention to and ultimately
serves as the mechanism from which the
climax's disaster stems from
superman something i haven't really
spoken about much in this series at all
has been superman and my experience with
the character growing up spider-man was
always my number one favorite i
identified with the character massively
and to this day his films can bring
tears to my eyes and while superman
isn't that nostalgic for me personally
he is for my little brother growing up
in the 90s my little brother adored
superman he had the toys watched the
movies and bought those tacky knock-off
superman costumes that never looked good
he would even watch that really old but
incredibly well animated superman tv
show from the 1940s too he had all of
those episodes on videotape and he
watched them so much he literally wore
out the tape and while i couldn't share
that same enthusiasm for the character
back then that he did today i'm still
delighted he was able to have that sort
of experience identifying with or
finding solace in that character in case
some of you are watching this in the
future during the spring of 2022 russia
launched an invasion of ukraine that
spun the world into a worldwide
at the moment of writing this there are
some horrific scenes reports and imagery
coming out of ukraine however in that
same vein there too have been some
heroic stories one that's been making
the rounds of light has been that of the
quote ghost of kiev the ghost of kiev is
a folktale that's been given to a yet
unnamed pilot of the ukrainian military
responsible for allegedly taking down
numerous russian fighter jets is the
story true possibly is the story
fabricated possibly too to tell you the
truth i honestly don't know but what i
do know is the impact such a story can
have on the terrified little children
that are hunkered down in subway
stations bunkers and basements across
that country hoping and praying for the
war to end and for their dads and
brothers to come home and for their
worlds to return to normal
in the last week the ghost of kiev has
become something of a mythical force
and this is what a superhero is
hope in the 1940s as countless husbands
brothers and uncles went off to fight in
the second world war not knowing if they
would ever return again for millions in
the united states superman as well as
other heroes of the time helped to
alleviate that anxiety injecting if only
for a moment some hope that someone
remarkable out there could take on
impossible odds and not only overcome
but save the day that's who superman was
for my little brother while spider-man's
appeal for me came from his relatability
and the themes of responsibility for my
brothers superman was the one hero that
when faced with two bad options could
always invent a third great one there's
a short sequence of scenes in this film
depicting what sort of force for good
superman can be and since seeing the
film back in 2016 one shot has always
stayed with me amidst the thrashing of
the rising tide hurricane winds and lack
of help a family is trapped atop the
roof of their home they have no options
until
there he is the last hope the option c
that shouldn't exist but does now to be
clear i'm not saying that this is who
superman needs to be in fact i'm by no
means an authority on superman i have
not read any of his comics and know very
little about his history instead i am
just saying that this was my exposure to
the character in my childhood and now as
an adult while i understand that a lot
of people don't like the god-like
imagery he's depicted with i personally
did like the vision behind a lot of
these ideas despite there being much
more to this character than i grew up
with initially
superman in this universe kills people i
feel conflicted on this topic somewhat
and perhaps that's the point if only one
person had a point of contention in this
fight between superman and batman then
it wouldn't be nearly as interesting and
so seeing as i have no real idea what
the definitive or de facto superman is
i'll accept this incarnation of the
character clark kent or kal-el in this
film i think is an interesting one he's
very much a small town middle america
sort of man and armed with those values
struggles to come to terms with what his
role in society ought to be with the
abilities he possesses and the
responsibilities that come bundled with
such otherworldly powers if with great
power comes great responsibility in
spider-man that in superman with
absolute power there must also come
absolute levels of responsibility and to
his credit he tries in earnest to stand
for something greater and important for
the here and now while being faced with
the grim reality his actions have
wrought onto this world so could you if
it was 1938 but it's not 1938.
i really liked this light and i think it
really speaks to the character and the
turmoil he seems to have found himself
in when superman was created in 1938 the
landscape was far simpler asking far
less of the superman character feats
that were fantastic and enemies that
were simple and clearly cut made up the
order of the day within the pages of the
old comic book things were far less
complicated and by extension far less
collateral damage was caused things are
no longer simple nowadays for this
character which is exactly the struggle
the modern incarnation of superman is
contending with and to be honest i think
that's a really interesting idea and
angle to take this character
bruce wayne meets clark kent
i love it lex luthor
no
jesse eisenberg okay where do i start
jesse eisenberg is a ridiculous choice
for lex luthor and before i dive into
this i should make it known that i have
no idea what the actual lex luthor in
the comics is supposed to sound like or
act like however i am familiar with a
little or should i say small show from
the early 2000s entitled smallville and
in that show lex luthor came across as
more of a cerebral emotionally stunted
hyper-intelligent troubled man not a
flamboyant eccentric megalomaniac in
this film jesse eisenberg plays him with
the same energy and vigor as a mark
zuckerberg on adderall and ecstasy
combined and i mean i totally understand
that that's largely what they're going
for here a young tech mogul type with a
psychotic streak but at no point does he
even remotely come close to the
appropriate levels of emotion for this
character and what's more is jesse
eisenberg is a ridiculously strange
choice for this role he comes across as
something more akin to a riddler or
joker type character than the suave
maniac luthor typically is where the
madness sits beneath the surface well
you look nervous
is it the scars and concerning eisenberg
i wouldn't even say his performance here
is necessarily bad or anything he's
clearly a talented actor and performs
the character he's being directed to
perform but the vision for the character
was all wrong with that said even though
this character is nothing like lex
luthor i do like what it offers the
story a paranoid and corrupt man hell
bent on controlling what he can even
when he can't the bittersweet pain among
men is having knowledge with no power
because
because that is paradoxical and
yielding lines with which we can better
understand the character like this while
delivering a speech full of half truths
he trips over his words momentarily with
a clear conflict descending over his
face
and in that moment speaks authentically
he's driven by similar urges to that of
batman in many respects which is fitting
as batman plays right into his hands
when he manipulates the world of those
two characters quite effortlessly which
ironically is perhaps the most lex
luthor thing he does in this film there
are moments where the ball drops and
suddenly we all realize what's about to
happen what a sick sense of humor
decorating a number of the choices he
makes to either take out or frame his
adversaries with take this courtroom
scene for example he wanted to frame
superman in this instance and take out
this woman standing in his way there was
no need for the jar of urine disguised
as peach tea sitting there but he did
that as a power play to call back to an
earlier conversation those two shared to
throw her own words right back in her
face before she dies to show and prove
to her that he was always in control
that's the kind of person we're dealing
with here however and this is a big
however while there are some upsides to
this otherwise perplexingly inaccurate
depiction of lex luthor what this
character offers the ending for me makes
absolutely no sense at all and really
only serves to add a profound air of
contrivance to the final battle with
doomsday lex managing to infiltrate a
weird kryptonian spaceship and
understanding in moments how to use it
to resurrect create his own monstrosity
using its technology feels extremely
contrived for the plot it's not like
it's intuitive either bearing in mind he
slashes his own hand pouring his own
blood over a corpse floating in yellow
goo am i expected to believe that he
managed to infer this by instinct and a
quick crash course in kryptonian
[ __ ] it's a ludicrous stretch
tell me
do you play it
batman versus superman as i mentioned
moments ago the action in this film is
really where it shines say what you want
about snyder's color palettes or his
directorial style but the man knows how
to shoot and direct an action scene i
love the way he shoots so much of the
superman vs zod battle from the ground
as if seen by a passerby it really helps
to create this unique sense of awe and
spectacle to the occasion furthermore
and this is a small personal choice i
liked when depicting metropolis and
gotham from afar or within he took
specific care to light them accordingly
shrouding gotham in shadows and
metropolis in sunshine light versus dark
just like the characters each city
represents but where this film's action
and nerdiness shines is in the fight
between batman and superman sponsored by
jesse eisenberg again similar to the
opening of this film this fight was one
of the two parts of this movie that i
actually liked although i did say at the
time that the fight between batman and
superman was a little on the short side
to justify the title seeing it today
however i am a lot more forgiving the
title of batman v superman isn't
implying fighting it implies conflict
and those are two very different things
outside of fighting physically both
bruce and clark contend with each other
either directly or indirectly numerous
times the two characters are clearly
facing their own individual and in many
ways diametrically opposing personal
issues which meet a swift resolution
once they do eventually come to blows
despite disliking or finding parts of
this film's narrative confusing with
regards to its ending i didn't see much
wrong with how they built up the
friction between bruce and clark in the
first place what draws them together
isn't their shared hatred but it's
another reason bruce and clark meet as i
mentioned in a party scene but later too
with batman chasing down a criminal and
superman trying to send batman a message
both of these encounters are spawned
from their innate desire to do good
however the conflict of the film stems
from their personal issues i alluded to
earlier that they need to rectify if
they're going to be capable of
reconciling their respective issues with
one another and these scenes prior to
their ultimate fight together while they
range in tone from suspicious of each
other to downright intimidation the only
reason these encounters happened at all
was due to their shared desire to better
the world which i thought was a
fantastic choice the fight that takes
place in this film between the two is
fittingly well choreographed and shot
better i think than any batman film i've
seen to date that scene where bruce
fights a host of criminals in the
warehouse is exactly the sort of energy
i was looking for from a batman action
sequence gone are the slow awkward
encounters with extras confused all over
the place and here to stay are some
truly jaw-dropping action scenes
furthermore in the fight between the two
titular characters batman has some
brilliant and introspective lines
directed towards clark he says breathe
it in that's fear and you're not brave
men are brave and how about this quote
you were never a god you weren't even a
man the story of batman throughout this
film has been how he's lost touch with
his humanity that has defined him as a
character throughout much of his modern
run which brings me to the martha scene
save
martha
when i first saw this scene i laughed
like a lot i found it utterly hilarious
in the cinema back in 2016 and looking
back on it i understand why the original
cut of this film for theaters was two
and a half hours long while this cut i
watched today was three hours long and
within that extra half an hour of
content comes some crucial part of the
story that never got given the chance to
really flourish the intro has possibly
the biggest change within the africa
section introducing a lady that lost her
family and blames superman for it as a
character she's so integral to painting
superman as a bad character but she's
not in the theatrical cut and as a
result the whole lois lane subplot makes
much less sense now with that said i
don't think the quote martha line
delivery and sudden realization on
behalf of batman is remarkable or
anything but at the very least it makes
sense within the story now as cringe as
that line is martha the mother of clark
plays a pivotal role in this film both
as a mentor or through reference by his
father's vision the movie goes to great
lengths to paint superman as a man
looking for guidance in an increasingly
complicated world that paints him as
some sort of god a role he has no
interest in playing on the flip side
batman's narrative is pretty much the
opposite people see him as a demon
that's lost his humanity so falls the
house of wayne bruce's family home is
left symbolic of how far he's fallen
from the man he once was he doesn't look
at superman as anything other than a
threat to humanity an alien from another
world that can't be trusted that must be
stopped the martha line itself serves to
paint superman not as a god among men
but as a person with a real humanity he
cares for his mother just like bruce and
in that sobering moment bruce comes to
realize the mistake he was moments away
from making a mistake that could have
cost him not only gotham not only what's
left of his humanity but the rest of the
world had he gone through with killing
clark the only person who could stop
doomsday the ending concerning doomsday
has some cool imagery like clark taking
a nuke in the face and being revived by
the sun a scene taken directly from the
dark knight returns comic but outside of
that there's not much else to praise and
that's the problem anything that isn't
dealing with either bruce or superman
directly feels contrived rushed or
misplaced wonder woman for the most part
is brilliant in this movie and doesn't
get in the way of the story being told
but that scene where she goes through
exposition.mp4 on the computer is a
beautiful example of this film trying to
carry more than it's capable of and it's
already bloated runtime but okay i've
spoken about this movie a lot already so
let's put a pin in this the best line
clark has in this film comes by way of
his final words to lois lane before he
sacrifices himself at the end throughout
this film he's grappled with why he is
doing what he's doing naturally he
possesses instincts and morals shaped by
the culture he was raised within but
through various conversations with his
mother and indeed a vision with his
father he suspects or perhaps fears that
his wish for himself isn't his own but
his father's however thankfully his
final words lay that to rest in
reference to protecting what's most
important to him he says
this is my world
you are my world directed towards his
love lois lane and accompanied by a lone
piano in the soundtrack that moment
comes across as stunningly beautiful
while this film did have a lot of issues
with its characters and its plot i was
surprised to see my impression of this
film changed completely after completing
this ultimate and extended edit of the
film the fight scenes are clearly the
best any batman character has ever seen
in live action and the final half of the
film while contrived in a few places is
a ton of fun with some interesting
storytelling at play with respect to the
batman and superman characters and in
the end that's the most important thing
in a film about these two characters in
short i'd watch this movie again the
goods certainly outweigh the obviously
bad i'd give it a 6.5 on a bad day or a
7 out of 10 if i'm feeling generous oh
ok finally we're done with this movie
okay time to move on to something
completely different so please welcome
[Music]
joker 2019
from the purposes of saving my fingers
from developing carpal tunnel due to the
already absurd length of the script i'm
gonna make this review short and sweet
this video is a batman review after all
and so it's only fair i spend more time
on his films where he actually appears
regarding joker people have a lot of
opinions on this movie some people love
it more than words can wield the matter
and others think that it's flat out
mediocre or insulting depending on where
you stand with this depiction of mental
illness i don't think i'm in any of
these camps personally so what is my
perspective on this flick
hey awful
oh can you get him
look
well i don't think this is the 10 out of
10 movie many might label it as being i
do think this is a fantastic and
compelling story joaquin phoenix once
again demonstrates why he's one of the
most talented and weirdest actors in
hollywood today there's plenty to
appreciate and love about this film from
its cinematography capturing the gritty
grimy realism of new york city where it
was shot to the breathtaking and
haunting performance of the deeply
troubled main character joker rightly
taking home the oscar for best actor in
2020 joaquin phoenix's performance as
the joker paints a contorted and deeply
upsetting picture of a tormented and
troubled man by the name of arthur as he
falls victim to a city that has devoured
both himself and his mother there's a
lot of social commentary in this film
concerning society and what it provides
or doesn't provide those that need it
and in a roundabout way i think that's
what i like about this movie much like
logan in 2017 this isn't your
run-of-the-mill by the books comic-based
film instead this is clearly a story
with a specific vision that a director
or writer thought was best served by the
joker as the main character it's not an
action adventure or anything remotely
related to that this is a psychological
thriller the likes of which i was left
thinking about weeks after the credits
rolled but unfortunately i wasn't
thinking about it for good reasons
exclusively joaquin's performance is a
10 out of 10 masterpiece and the film is
shot beautifully however my issues stem
from the concepts of homage and
imitation if one film is to pay homage
to another that is to take inspiration
from a particular idea i find that it is
most successful when done so in a
fashion that says something that the
other work either did not or could not
say for instance take quentin
tarantino's award-winning film django
unchained this film takes inspiration
from the ideas techniques and stories
popularized within the old american
western films however what makes django
unchained a homage and not an imitation
in my eyes is that this is a film that
wasn't and in many ways couldn't have
been made in that format during the time
period westerns were popular or if you
want to stick with the superhero genre
we can take logan for example much like
django it takes inspiration from old
western films like shane there are other
clear inspirations like the wrestler and
children of men too but shane is deeply
entrenched in the dna of logan so much
so that the film even makes a cameo in
the logan movie shane tells the story of
an old gunslinger that rides into town
to start a new life before becoming a
father figure to another young child
there are integral elements that make
the spirits of these stories logan and
shane similar however they both when
utilizing what makes their respective
stories unique tell different stories or
convey different messages in ways that
only their films can and this is where i
think joker blurs the gap between homage
and imitation looking at joker it's
plain as day that todd phillips the
director of joker took elements from the
film's taxi driver and the king of
comedy both directed by martin scorsese
because of this some of the best
cinematography in the film takes
explicit cues from these films such that
the directorial language mimics
scorsese's to an almost obsessive degree
while also from a story perspective
because these films cover subject matter
that is so similar to that of the joker
it's difficult to discern what this film
brings to the table that the other films
would not have furthermore it's even
more difficult to imagine what joker
might have looked like or would have
even tried to say without these films
having already clearly blazed a trail on
which this film so elegantly dances upon
now in saying that i'm not suggesting
that i didn't like the joker at all the
king of comedy and taxi driver are some
of my absolute favorite films and to see
a modern spin on these ideas with a
joker twist was quite interesting i
really liked the model nature with which
joker's thoughts blurred the lines of
reality and delusion seamlessly it
served to really enhance the story that
was being told while building joker up
to be the sympathetic monster he
eventually becomes and wanted to be
recognized as and i guess i like that
the film story could very well have been
a lie told by joker in a hospital
towards the end i just would have
preferred or found it more interesting
for this film to feel more like it had
something unique to say or had more of
its own visual language incorporated
into the film todd phillips is clearly a
talented filmmaker and i really do
believe he's going to be making some
fantastic films in the future but when
you compare his other films to this
these feel like todd films while this
one here distinctly feels scorsese
having said all of that i still really
like the joker i think it's one of the
few comic book films that could actually
be viewed by anyone and everyone over
the recommended age and with an
award-winning performance by the phoenix
man himself there's a lot to respect and
enjoy my final score for this film is an
8 out of 10. now it's time to watch
something i've never seen before that's
right i'm talking about zack snyder's
justice league from 2021 i haven't even
watched this film yet and i'm already
exhausted just looking at its runtime
way back when i first watched batman vs
superman in theaters i had such a bad
time watching that film that i pretty
much gave up on all things dc after that
for quite some time i did end up seeing
wonder woman through a friend and to my
surprise i actually had a great time
watching it there are some truly awesome
scenes in that film not just including
the no man's land scene and i thought
diana's wonder woman was a truly sweet
and good hero for us all to follow along
with on these adventures this in turn
gave me hope in 2017 for the justice
league film and that's when my friend
told me about his experience
he didn't like it in fact for your
entertainment since i never saw the
original justice league i asked three of
my friends if they could give me their
one sentence review of that movie these
are those reviews
friend number one justice league is like
a wolf in sheep's clothing something
totally different twisted into a watered
down joke fest with no soul and a
blatant attempt to recreate the magic of
the avengers with which it falls short
in every conceivable way friend number
two this film is carried by its
character interactions but ultimately
falls to pieces with no real central
driving force and a villain with so
little presence that any sense of a
justice league level threat is
completely non-existent and finally my
personal favorite friend three's review
i pirated it and i still felt ripped off
great reviews guys so if that was the
general impression from fans of the
characters towards the end of 2017 let's
see how my feelings compare in this zack
schneider cut
that was a [ __ ] wild experience with
some truly brilliant moments and that's
not to say that i didn't have my issues
with this one from time to time i bet
this is a common complaint but the first
90 minutes to two hours of the film
really dragged for me with that said i
knew exactly what they were doing
establishing the main cast in
steppenwolf the flash aquaman and cyborg
who all play very important roles in
this film and they do a really good job
of that in this movie in addition to
reintroducing wonder woman who's saving
people batman who's recruiting people
and superman who's super dead now after
the last film the structure of this
movie particularly in the first half
interests me to an almost pathological
degree this is a four hour film and boy
did i feel every agonizing second of
that time this film is broken into a
series of chapters and due in part to
that i don't think i can see this as a
film but instead more like a hybrid of a
series and a film put together it's like
this ridiculous high-budget tv program
that someone cut the intros off of
slapped them together and called it a
day it feels extremely thorough in
explaining what's going on and showing
what people are doing almost to its
detriment like you know with books they
usually adapt the material to work for a
film well this feels like a book in many
ways that didn't adapt its material for
the screen and admittedly this does have
a lot of positives before this film
began i knew virtually nothing about
half of the individuals that made up the
justice league proper aquaman flash
cyborg to be exact and due to this film
being effectively long enough to jam two
average length feature films into these
characters all felt fully explored
before the plot demanded anything
significant of them there are also some
really really cool quotes this one for
example i can't sit here watching you
run in place for some dead end dude
who's not going anywhere that's a
fantastic quote from flash's dad because
it lets us know exactly what barry's
been doing in a very efficient amount of
time while also telling us a bit about
himself or how about this quote i've
spent enough time trying to divide us i
should try to bring us together a
wonderful line from batman that speaks
to the growth his character has
undergone while also helping us to
understand his role in the group he's a
leader a facilitator someone that feels
a deep responsibility for this world and
these people cyborg gets a ton of
backstory in this film also and it's to
the film's benefit for sure there's this
scene that shows him running down a
football field and i swear that's the
most zack snyder thing i've seen since
the 300 in fact that specific shot i'm
sure was in both films however with that
said i don't think this film justifies
its run time at all there are scenes
like when a bunch of scandinavian women
sing to aquaman or when stefan wolf
fights a bunch of atlanteans or wonder
woman telling us what happened once upon
a time thousands of years ago and it's
just not that interesting to me i
understand that this is all part of what
builds up the midpoint climax and
ultimately the conclusion of this film
and yet i can't help but feel like this
film could have shaved off 45 minutes
and seen some massive benefits the first
90 minutes of this i found to be a real
slog and by the time i got to the
halfway point where things really
started to pick up while i enjoyed it i
needed to take a break as the movie
hadn't progressed in a significant
enough fashion to entice me to hang on
any further is that a problem well it
depends on what you want from a movie i
guess on one hand i found this film to
be quite long-winded but at the same
time i've become captivated by the
journey this film has undergone and this
was something i only recently learned
about thanks to my friend who filled me
in on everything originally planned to
complete this zach lost out on his
original vision for this film due to the
tragic death of his daughter forcing him
to step away and leave the production to
joss whedon the finished product ended
up sucking tremendously and warner
brothers basically handed the entire
franchise there and then as a result it
took fans years of complaining to get
warner brothers to allow snyder the
chance to finish his original vision and
so as a result this is very much a
completely unrestrained film that tries
to do everything it can with the
knowledge that there ultimately probably
won't be more and so while that doesn't
invalidate how you or i might feel about
this film's long-windedness i think it's
kind of nice to have a properly
authorized superhero movie that holds
nothing back
justice league versus superman right
before the justice league fights
superman after he gets undefined the
team unite against steppenwolf to close
out the first two hours of the film that
unification sort of acts as the midpoint
climax and to the film's credit i really
thought that was a strong moment much
needed too as they up until that point
hadn't been seen much together and at
that point i was also concerned that
this film wasn't going to create any
moments for the team to actually talk to
each other to converse to argue to
really explore their dynamics however
thankfully though they get to do just
that as they deliberate over what they
ought to do with superman cyborg and
aquaman share some tender moments
together along with flash diana 2 with
bruce and it's moments like these that
really make me want to root for these
characters and i needed that because
superman was awesome in this movie the
revival of superman with the justice
league subsequent fight against him
might be my favorite part of this film
save for the endings fight perhaps both
of which happen to include superman
watching clark body literally everyone
in his team with ease shows just how
powerful he is when he's not restrained
by his humanity not to mention how scary
he can be flash was someone i thought
was incredible in this film by the way
and facilitates some of the best moments
in the entire movie i swear when flash
runs past superman at a ridiculously
fast speed and clark's eyes tracked him
i actually got chills it was such an
incredible moment capped off by the most
important thing in his life bringing him
back from the brink lois lane
justice league versus steppenwolf
there's a moment in this fight that
reawakens something inside of me that i
thought had died long ago this childlike
sense of wonder when looking at a
superhero and it was for a character i
never felt a strong connection to i told
you all earlier in this video that
superman was my brother's hero while
spider-man was mine and to tell you the
truth i never really understood what he
saw him i could only speculate based on
what he told me however in the closing
moments of that fight with everyone on
the back foot flash waiting on standby
in cyborg in a very compromising
position i understood
[Music]
when superman showed up at the last
second with me having grown closer to
all of these characters for him to make
that save at that moment like that i
lost my collective [ __ ] and i knew i had
to record my reaction to this live
okay guys i'm gonna be recording my live
reaction i haven't seen this part of the
movie i've seen
one hype moment that happens in like
three seconds but everything after that
i have no idea i start i thought like
it'd be cool to record my reaction
because what happens
really [ __ ] blew me away so okay
without further ado here are my live
unfiltered reactions to the final
40 minutes of
zack snyder's justice league from 2021.
here we go
[Music]
not impressed that was the vote that was
the moment i knew was coming oh this is
the hype of [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh this is sick like they're all kind of
working together now like it's just so
[ __ ] cathartic
this is that option c this is that
option cm was talking about earlier
where he kind of provides that option
that like you don't even think is
possible sit the [ __ ] down does he heal
faster too i mean that would make sense
like metabolism but wouldn't that mean
that he ages faster too oh
[ __ ]
it's that guy from that flashback like
three hours ago
holy [ __ ] okay
this is [ __ ] huge like the scope of
this is crazy make your own future oh my
[ __ ] god that is such a great line
okay yep that'll work there's a really
nice kind of coming of full circle with
all of their characters you know batman
you know assuming the responsibility of
humanity and you know wanting to do the
best for it you know retrieving his own
humanity you know clark kind of like
reconciling his emotions regarding his
own sense of self and what his purpose
is wonder woman's always been perfect
apparently
black had his nice character arc in this
with his dad and him kind of reconciling
that he is going to be able to make his
own future and make something of himself
cyborg was able to let go of the past
and you know that resentment that he has
and he's able to accept himself for who
he is
i i can't get used to william the phone
in this movie
i think something that this movie did
really well was
assigned time proportionately and
appropriately to each individual
character without one feeling more
slated than the other
like they gave a lot of backstory to
aquaman flash and
uh cyborg in this movie that was much
needed batman sort of took a driving
role which made him have utility in the
movie because i mean he doesn't have a
lot of powers but he's got a lot of
resources and he brought everything
together and superman obviously is
superman then at the end making like one
of the best action sequences i've seen
committed to a superhero film so
everything seemed like it had its place
and was really kind of part of
everything and obviously then wonder
woman was wonder woman and she
is great and everything she might
actually be my favorite of all of these
characters
what what the [ __ ] is happening
that was sick
that was a sick movie okay critics okay
let's go okay okay
overall thoughts they had that amazing
ending and
that really weird dystopian ending that
i don't know how to make sense of quite
yet uh
it's it this this reads like they want
to do another one but
uh
i don't know if they ever will uh if
they do let me know
overall
i loved this movie it was a film unlike
any i think i've ever seen and for that
reason alone i'm excited by the fact
that it even exists at all the more
variety in superhero films we have the
more opportunities we have for terrific
stories to be told in a wider array of
ways this was clearly a film with a
dedicated vision orchestrating its
creation and fueled by the passion of
billions around the world young and old
and today i honestly think i felt a
connection to these characters in a way
i never thought i ever would my final
score for this is an outstanding 8 out
of 10. slow start but what an incredible
finish
hey guys what's going on totally not
mark here i am definitely not making
this video like this because i forgot to
make a g field commercial i'm making
this because it's perfect really high
production too like all the other g fuel
commercials
please guys if you guys want to support
my channel or show appreciation to g
fuel for sponsoring this video uh please
check the link in the description pick
up some g fuel for yourself i actually
use it every day for whenever i do my
workout i'm doing a long distance
running now preparing for a marathon so
if you guys want something that you
think is tasty and caffeine free or if
you want the sugar variety then by all
means pick it up in the description down
below using the coupon code that i have
down there please um
anything else do i have anything else um
enjoy the video
okay so you might be wondering at this
point where my review for robert
pattinson's film the batman is right
well i saw it last night and i am in the
middle of making it and truth be told i
really wanted to finish it in time for
this video but the length of this once
again got out of control but fret not
you won't have to wait long as i will be
releasing that review tomorrow and
spoiler alert it's my new favorite
batman film and might be up there as one
of my favorite film experiences of all
time for that and more please subscribe
to stay in the loop i'll see you all
tomorrow with the last batman review
you